[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute einen
schaum kuchen und ich habe mir gedacht
gerade weil aktuell das wetter auch so
heiß ist und die sonne ist da sollte es
ein rezept sein für das er den backofen
nicht anschmeißen ist und wir starten
jetzt zuallererst mit dem boden
ich mache jetzt einen boden aus dem
mister jamie keksen von kay classics von
kaufland das sind diese hier die werde
ich jetzt hier ganz einfach fein mixen
und anschließend kommt da einfach ein
bisschen geschmolzene butter dazu und
das ist dann schon unser boden
[Musik]
die butter vermischt er dann zusammen
mit den keksen und das ist quasi unser
noweck boden der eignet sich nämlich so
immer perfekt für solche torten und
kuchen und den gibt jetzt einfach auf
den boden eurer schnitten form ich nehme
heute nämlich einschnitten form er
könnte das rezept natürlich umwandeln
und ein ganzes blech vormachen das ist
vollkommen euch überlassen
ich kann auch gerne auch eine umrechnung
tabelle in die infobox verlegen genauso
wie alle ganz genauen mengenangaben das
habe ich jetzt hier noch glaubt
verstrichen und schön an gedrückt und
das kommt jetzt bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
und ich zeige euch jetzt mal richtig
kohle und ausgeklügelte creme
so kann man wird unsere ausgeklügelten
creme dafür benötigen wir tatsächlich
auch nur drei zutaten und zwar milch
sahne und dann habe ich als dritte zutat
creme pulver das ist nicht pudding
pulver das ist ja dann zum kochen wir
brauchen aber ein system zum aufschlagen
verwendet das heißt eincremen pulver das
eben nicht ein kocht nicht dass ihr tier
auch anhand der packungsanleitung und
ihr müsst aber ganz wichtig auf meine
mengenangaben achten wenn ich habe zum
beispiel die milch ein bisschen
reduziert wir wollen eine feste torten
creme und nicht einfach eine creme zum
löffeln so und jetzt machen wir
folgendes wir vermischen jetzt ganz
einfach alles in der küchenmaschine ihr
könnt aber auch euer handrührgerät
verbinden die milch die hab ich
abgebogen gebe ich hier einmal rein
sagen mit rein denn das pulver mit dazu
und dann ganz einfach aufschlagen
[Musik]
und die schaum creme ist fertig ungefähr
23 minuten hat förmige dauer und jetzt
gebe ich das ganz einfach auf den
vorbereiteten boden und streicht das
noch so ein bisschen das geht dabei in
der regel wie von alleine
[Musik]
so und jetzt heißt es ganz viel geduld
zeigen ich bin selbst ein mega
ungeduldiger mensch aber wenn es um
torten geht und ich weiß macht derzeit
schminken sie richtig richtig gut dann
halte ich das auch aus also mindestens
vier stunden in den kühlschrank damit
noch besser wäre natürlich über nacht
dann könnt ihr das ja auch am vortag
zubereiten ganz chile ich am nächsten
tag verspeisen und wenn ihr möchte das
mache ich nämlich so gibt ihr obendrauf
noch ein bisschen zeit später kuvertüre
oder freue mich wenn ihr mögt oder weiße
kuvertüre geht auch ich russell das dann
ganz schön oben drauf und dann ist
eigentlich mein schauen kuchen fertig
das ganze baic superschnell suppe
einfach wenig zutaten und die zutaten
bekommt natürlich alle bei kaufland und
ansonsten würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr
mir unten in die kommentare schreibt was
er als nächstes sehen möchtet mehr
neubeck rezepte vielleicht passend zum
sommer nämliche grillrezepte schreibt es
mir gerne rein cocktail super gute idee
alkoholfreie cocktails und dann ja würde
ich mal sagen sehen wir uns bei meinem
nächsten rezepttipps eure ki ka und ford
und auf instagram da gibt es dann den
test zu dieser standorte oder diesem
kuchen bis bald
[Musik]